well Human Nature has shared their
talents with us for years in Las Vegas
and they are continuing to do so with
some special shows planned at the South
Point joining us today are your favorite
Aussie singers we have Andrew Michael
and Toby you guys so great to see you
thanks for being here I have always been
a huge fan of you guys and what I love
most is anytime you come to one of your
shows everyone in the audience is up and
dancing and singing along is that the
vibe that you want people to feel
whenever and wherever they see you guys
perform absolutely yeah I mean just
seeing people get into these songs is
amazing that you know there's such
classic songs as well we didn't throw a
couple of our original songs in there
which is fun but um yeah everybody's
singing along and dancing by the end and
it's uh it's a hold of fun well we're
seeing some video on the screen here
that is just a little taste of what you
can expect and you guys have been
performing on and off at South Point
lately but we have a very special
announcement happening exclusively here
on Las Vegas now and I'm so excited you
might notice I am holding some cowboy
hats here so Mr on over at Southpoint
wanted me to officially welcome you to
the South Point Family can you tell us
wow yes you guys look officials you're
doing a resume residency
we are extending our residence here at
South Point it's been amazing we've done
14 shows so far and they've all been
sold out this is
like I don't know for performing
them no it's a great place too to be the
the people there are so friendly and
it's just been
um fantastic yeah to do these shows and
now we're extending them through to June
next year 2023. congratulations
so yeah what can we expect at the show
Motown is your thing um but you know
when people come see this new residency
what are you giving them well it's been
awesome we've actually done we did some
shows through this year and every show
got sold out so it's been amazing so um
when Mr gone said would we extend
through till June next year we thought
awesome but we need hats
official it's been such a beautiful
showroom and I think it's one of the
best casinos on the strip and they talk
about this South End boom in Las Vegas
and the whole The Whole Town's moving
south so we're going to be there ready
to party yeah absolutely yes you guys
are in a great spot and in addition to
that you also have your holiday show
tell us about that what can we expect
well there's not any cowboy hats in the
holiday show you never know yes
we love it when we
to the the holiday show because I mean
it's just such a wonderful time of year
um and everybody gets into the spirit
and we did some at South Point last year
that's sort of what kicked off uh our
residency there so yeah it's uh there's
still some Motown in there but all your
Christmas favorites and um a bit of a
few jokes a bit of fun and you guys
always have fun on stage it's always
exciting we're planning some special uh
we might have sexual cowboy hats oh my
gosh with a bit of neon give it away
little cheese you're making us all want
to come out I'm so excited for you guys
you're actually from Australia but now
Las Vegas is home to you how does it
feel to have the support of the
community I mean it's got to be so much
fun they keep coming they want to see
you guys it's amazing actually I mean
we've been here what 12 years now 13
years in Vegas and it's just it is great
to feel that you know we feel love from
people when they come to the shows and
they um they come up and they've been
supporting us for that many years too so
and it's it's amazing you know after the
pandemic and everything we we wondered
if we'd get a chance to to have a home
on the Strip again but now
um being at South Point it's just
fantastic you found your home we love
you here in Las Vegas congratulations
human nature you've already here at Las
Vegas now first they have the cowboy
hats to prove it the human nature
residency back to the sound of Motown is
coming to the South Point Hotel this
2023 tickets go on sale tomorrow for
tickets and more information you can
visit southpointcasino.com and now we
are in for a special treat enjoy this
performance from Human Nature
dude
[Music]
people say I'm alive
deep inside I'm Blue
should take a good
my face you see my smile
smiles
[Music]
please if you look closer and see
the trains
the Tracks Of My Tears
do